there are many big human rights
challenges today on the one hand there
are the mass atrocities places like
Darfur or eastern Congo where where many
many people are killed and displaced
there are highly repressive governments
say North Korea or Burma or Becca Stan
or Turkmenistan we are just the severity
of the government repression deserves
attention there are places where wars
have become so chaotic that that the
lack of government is a problem I think
your rock is an example of that so in
that sense there are many situations
where where violence and repression call
out for urgent attention but there are
other you know quieter forms of abuse
that we tend not to you tend not to see
in the headlines but that nonetheless
affect many many people quite severely
and here I think about say that the
severe restrictions on on the rights of
women that exist in many parts of the
world I think about migrant workers who
are forced to travel long distances and
in a foreign environment often are exist
completely without respect for rights
holy at the whim of their employer I
think about you know children who may be
drafted to be soldiers almeria
physically seized and course to become
soldiers or who have to serve as
domestics in lieu of going to school so
there many of these quieter issues that
don't get into the headlines but that
are also quite acute problems as well
you